[Music]
did you happen to vote in november's
election
i did great have you ever heard of
proposition 22
no i didn't are you familiar with
proposition 22
yeah no i don't know the ins and outs of
prop 22 unfortunately
not off the top of my head no no i don't
no sir
no no
in california everyone from uber drivers
to instacart delivery workers
are classified as independent
contractors they are the backbone
of the gig economy in america's biggest
state
in 2019 california enacted assembly bill
5 a law to improve working conditions
for those workers essentially
classifying them not as independent
contractors
but as full employees
[Music]
ab5 passed despite the you know the
incredibly aggressive lobbying of these
very powerful tech firms
it was really an example of democratic
lawmaking
in order to carve themselves out of the
newly passed assembly bill
5 doordash lyft and uber put forth an
initial
90 million dollars towards a new ballot
measure
proposition 22 to give you a rough idea
of of what is on the line when it comes
to classification it's
unemployment insurance minimum wage osha
protections
it's so many things that are not just
how much you're paid and what hours you
get they were going to go to the ballot
no matter what
whether ab5 existed or not to make an
exception for their industry
so they can continue to profit while the
workers suffer and the taxpayers
when a worker doesn't have health
insurance when a worker doesn't get
minimum wage
when a worker doesn't have workers come
we paid for it so we're basically
subsidizing
billions and billions of dollars that
these companies are making off of
californians
they pour 200 million dollars into a
massive commercial advertisement
mailing campaign they actually made it
look like
they were doing this to protect their
workers proposition 22 was
advertised as this bold new law that was
going to give
all these new benefits and the campaign
did a really good job
of instrumentalizing race they had
women of color who represented
themselves as you know single moms
um immigrant men talking about how they
couldn't survive
off of their full-time job and how they
really needed the flexibility of this
work
and so the law was advertised as
actually something that would
provide new benefits to this very very
vulnerable workforce
as opposed to something that would take
away benefits
from the workforce and in fact that is
exactly what the law did
the two buzzwords that the yes on a prop
22 campaign really relied upon
were independence and flexibility but i
mean i signed up for uber because of the
freedom and the flexibility
if you vote yes you're keeping that
flexibility if you vote no
you're kind of eliminating that
flexibility one thing that's important
in california i think we can all agree
on
is the need for uber and lyft
oh yes on prop 22. vote yes on props 22.
they were constantly bombarding drivers
with this
information that if they didn't vote yes
on on prop 22 if prop 22 didn't pass
then their scheduling flexibility was
going to be completely taken away
i mean i'm not really big on politics
but from what i understood on the
commercials
the california's trying to get us to
become employees of grubhub and things
like that
i just want to stay independent
contractor and just keep on doing what
i'm doing
work what i want if i want to take the
weekend off i'll take the weekend off
what was shocking i would say is some of
the tactics that they were willing to
resort to
things like having us affix propaganda
to the deliveries that we were making
including propaganda that we had to you
know
hit okay or i agree to before we were
able to move on and continue to do the
rest of our work
as soon as you open up the app you you
have a big a big screen that says
bought yes on prop22 and this is why if
you don't vote yes on prop 22 we're
gonna leave california
we're gonna schedule you hours you're
gonna lose your flexibility
you're only gonna drive certain amount
of hours i mean they were saying
so much stuff you know like they were
scaring drivers if the only sort of
income is
over you're gonna be afraid that you're
going to lose your job one of the other
tactics that this campaign used quite
effectively
was harassment and intimidation people
who supported prop 22
doxxed me on the internet i've done
political activism for
20 years at this point and this was the
most intimidated i have ever felt
old-school union busting tactics the
factories are going to close if we don't
get what we want
it's exactly what that is only they were
able to reach people
instantaneously through these apps
even at the height of the pandemic while
these companies were messaging we care
about workers so much
and we want to increase standards for
them that prop 22 would enshrine somehow
they were still failing to meaningfully
provide any kind of protection to get
workers even though we were deemed
essential
[Music]
instacart i think and shipped probably
are two of the most egregious and that
we're going into a hotbed for covet
grocery stores
and we have no meaningful access to any
kind of protection to keep ourselves
safe
while instacart is growing exponentially
and profiting
off of the pretense that we're going to
keep our customers safe
i didn't have access to things like hand
sanitizer or disinfectants i was
literally spraying my hands
with everclear to try and keep them
clean while i was working
everyone else was able to file for
emergency unemployment insurance and
uber and lyft drivers
were stuck in a limbo because these
companies have not paid
millions of dollars into state
unemployment insurance taxes
it was very hard for drivers to get
help you know to get unemployment a lot
of drivers gave up
yeah it was a woman actually she
couldn't wait anymore
you know she'd started driving she
caught covered
and she was dead within three weeks
the only way to combat the
misinformation campaign from the
companies
was getting them real data and real
information
about what the consequences of prop 22
would look like
ride share drivers pack the streets in
opposition to prop
22. drivers against prop 22 hit the road
with a message
when you work with uber and lyft what
have they done for drivers over the
years
i'm asking my friends and family to vote
no on prop 22 because they support
worker rights over corporate grief we
work weeks
and weeks after weeks making phone calls
calling other drivers calling
the general public sending text message
reality is there's no way we can match
the money
but we do have the people power drivers
are coming together to demand their
rights
and that's what we have we have drivers
with their authentic voice not paid
spokespeople
who have actually driven for uber and
lyft who know that their employee status
is important and that they deserve paid
sick leave california propositions now
prop 22 this is the big one uber and
lyft want this to pass
and as of right now nbc news is
projecting the prop 22 will pass
no matter how strong criticism from gig
worker activists was
the influence of gig work companies was
stronger
proposition 22 passed with 59
of the vote will you do this in other
states absolutely i think that the next
step is to work with
politicians regulators drivers and
potentially labor leaders hopefully
across the country to bring this to more
places
one of the pieces of the proposition
that was unheard of was that it requires
a 7
8 majority of the california legislature
to
pass anything related to workers rights
what is really key to understand is how
amazingly anti-democratic this is
7 8 is insane i've said it before and
i'll say it again
proposition 22 is the most dangerous
piece
of legislation that i have seen in my
lifetime the possibility for us
to spread this to other industries it's
retail
restaurant work healthcare and education
eventually
if we don't wake up if we don't fight
against these big corporations
eventually everything is gonna is gonna
work through an app
if uber and liv were able to ride their
own law
what's preventing from walmart home
depot target to do the same thing
drivers for supermarkets all over
california will soon be out of a job
albertson's companies plan to let go
those workers and instead
use independent contractors there had
been so many assurances that this wasn't
going to disrupt labor markets that it
was just going to improve conditions for
workers coming from the prop 22 campaign
that turned out very quickly to be alive
is it fair
to have companies like yours
essentially setting labor law across the
country
no it's not the role of a company to set
labor law you know i wish you could get
all money out of politics
and just have have good conversations
but there's there's money on both sides
there's influence on both sides
although let's be fair the pro forces
spent
more than 200 million dollars on prop 22
the con forces
spent not even 20 million dollars yeah
if you look at it that way
that's fair there's an ad for instacart
that i've seen a lot lately
that i think represents exactly what's
going on with these gig economy
companies you see all these families
spending quality time together
not spending time going to the grocery
store and then towards the end
you see this shot of someone carrying
groceries except it cuts off at their
neck
so it's literally removing the
personhood of the person who's
delivering your groceries
in order to give this benefit to this
middle-class family so that they could
have more time
if this is something that scares you as
much as it scares me
i think that there is a lot that we need
to do immediately
to mobilize to ensure that proposition
22 is
upended on the federal level i'm really
excited about the possibility of the pro
act which would perhaps most centrally
make clear
that all working people have the right
to organize with one another
to raise wages and working conditions
the only way that we can stop this from
just getting worse stop the united
states from deteriorating to a place
that was during the great depression to
address food insecurity to address
housing insecurity to make sure that
people's quality of lives is what they
should be
in the wealthiest country in the world
is to pass the pro act
the workers that are impacted by
proposition 22 are doing everything they
can and their limited power
to ensure that that happens and we just
need more people
to stand behind it
[Music]
you